britney spears is going bold on social
media
over the weekend the pop icon shared two
topless photos of herself to instagram
the pics were seemingly taken in her
backyard brittany posted this photo on
friday
and this one on saturday for both posts
brittany took a break from her long
captions
a potted plant accompanied the first
pick and three shining stars are seen
next to the second shot
each photo currently has over two and a
half million likes
and her celebrity fans are here for the
near new looks
snooki comm in it quote gimme gimme more
shay mitchell simply left these fire
emojis
paris hilton one of brittany's high
profile supporters amid her
conservatorship battle
dropped both of her trademark catch
phrases that's hot
and slimming for when you're both
slaying and living your best
life and she's just so sweet and down to
earth and
really an amazing woman and i'm just so
proud of her
meanwhile og britney supporter chris
crocker wrote
the spirit of freedom the new post
follows a series of candid messages
brittany's been sharing to instagram
on thursday brittany hinted that she
loves being able to drive by herself
which follows her bombshell testimony
last month where britney claims she's
been unable to do so under her
conservatorship
when did you last feel free
when i got to drive my car a lot britney
even voiced her frustration about it in
this bonus scene from the documentary
brittany for the record which premiered
in 2008
the year her conservatorship was put
into place i love driving my car
something about being able to drive your
car that allows freedom
and i haven't been able to drive my car
a week ago brittany also clapped back at
criticism of the dance video
she's been sharing to instagram
[Music]
brittany said she won't be performing on
stage quote anytime
soon because the control her father
jamie spears would have over her
performance
am i going to take the stage again will
i ever take the stage again
i have no idea brittany wrote i'd much
rather share videos
yes from my living room instead of on
stage in vegas
she added quote my so-called support
system hurt me deeply
this week britney's legal battle
continues and a new layer of urgency
hangs over the proceedings
on monday brittany's temporary
conservator jody montgomery
will be requesting 24 7 security after
claiming she's been receiving death
threats from brittany's fans
what today was about was an issue
concerning security
brittany's safety was also discussed in
court last week
and e.t heard from her new attorney
matthew rosengart who gave a brief
statement following the hearing
i once again want to thank britney
spears for her courage
and for her strength and i also want to
thank britney spears fans and supporters
outreach and support for my firm myself
and most importantly brittany has truly
been overwhelming
finally and the last thing i'm going to
say about this matter
is as i said in court last week
and outside my firm and i are moving
aggressively and expeditiously
to file a petition to remove jamie
spears
unless he resigns first thank you